you're a fact guy you're a factor you're
a man I've always kind of battled the
dark arts overall so it's like I've
never really looked at a ton of the
facts you know it's always been this
more ethereal sort of what you want to
be true rather than what is true I took
one class out in Arizona at pretty high
altitude you know what they say that if
you learn something under certain
psychomotor conditions that you recover
it better under those same conditions oh
wow like if you get high and you learn
something if you get high again later
you remember that better because you
match the mental States oh say aliens
show up right
is there a society or culture or
ethnicity that's best evolved you think
to handle it scientists really
scientists
go ahead Theo if an alien landed right
in front of us and said to you Theo take
me to your leader are you going to take
him to the White House
no no of course not are you thinking to
Congress no no that's a great question
what's my point you would take him to
well I'm not going to speak for you but
I happen to be a scientist but if I were
not a scientist I would take him to a
scientist you would yes a biologist or a
a physicist somebody who's by the way
say science is closed that day
come back out to lunch come back
tomorrow open at nine in the morning so
you know even science has a sandwich bro
who where would you take him you speak
of science like is the one dude behind
the counter
behind the Lunch Counter hey I'm just
saying no where would you take him then
no wait let me let me finish what
happens if you're trying to talk to him
okay my point is mathematics I give him
a treat first I think you'd have to
treat they're not a pet they just flew
here in a ship way more advanced than
anything we've ever conceived you're
gonna here it's a chew toy
dude I'm just saying you guys
then your friend forever
where they're eating what are they the
the Reese's Pieces no no oh yeah well
he'd bring his friends next week now you
give a Reese's to an alien it's gonna
get diabetes how do you know it can
handle it it's just so pretty
that's a good point bro now he's stuck
what if he becomes all lazy and stuff
when you start getting them acclimated
it's fat and lazy on Earth that has to
be a movie right let's do a movie like
that I don't know but okay so he's here
what do you do what I'm saying is that
I have a periodic table of elements that
are elements across the universe I know
mathematics that laws of physics that
apply Across the Universe they got here
from across the universe so those those
laws would be totally the same when
they're planning totally the same so if
you're gonna start with a language like
oh this is a cup and this is a fork and
this is it's like this is our elements
and this is we call this aluminum we
call this and they will know and they
start to develop a common vocabulary so
that you can communicate with them
because they're not going to speak
English nor French nor Mandarin none of
the above that being said if they send
radio signals here the largest radio
telescope is going to pick it up first
and you know where that is hold on let
me think Arizona uh it was once in on
American soil in Puerto Rico the the art
of sibo telescope but that collapsed out
of disuse and okay the largest radio
telephone in the world is in China wow
so the first humans that will hear hear
the signal sent by aliens will be
Chinese astrophysicists
but we're talking about if they visit so
if they visit I'm saying bring them to a
scientist the scientists will know how
to think about and pose questions to
them so the Chinese would be the first
people to know that right no no to hear
a signal okay that comes over do you
think that they would tell the rest of
us or not probably not initially but uh
but eventually no no the thing is why
why should they they they built their
own Dan telescope that telescope is a
mile in circumference by the way you
want to get a sense of how big it is
it's called the fast telescope 500 meter
aperture spherical telescope acronym
fast but if they know and they don't
tell us man
but then they get to they can they
can have a heart attack and they say we
are the chosen ones and everyone else on
Earth isn't let's send your ray beams to
you know I don't know what they're gonna
do
um but there it is uh we have another
image
oh we are we're looking at the image on
the screen I was that visited that we
filmed there for Cosmos what oh my gosh
bro you gotta hold on to that footage oh
my gosh we gotta make this why are we
why don't we have anything like that
because we are not we'd like to think of
ourselves we're Americans and we're
really we're we are we over history
we've been reactive
two challenges from other countries not
proactive and what are we now as far as
when it comes to challenges from outer
space we have nothing that Rivals that
wow at all is outer space gay or
straight is outer space gay or straight
practically everything we see and
measure in space
not only objects but temperature size
density
is on a spectrum
so for you to say is the universe gay or
straight
I'm going to tell you whatever the
universe is it's on a spectrum
okay in fact the very word spectrum
comes from what happens when you take
light and break it up into its colors we
just happen to assign names to the seven
colors
red orange yellow green blue indigo
violet but it's an it's a continuum
we're just being lazy by assigning seven
colors our brain doesn't want to see
nuance
because it's easier for us to think in
binary so it's are you with me or are
you against me well maybe you're
somewhere in between are you a boy are
you a girl maybe they're expressing
themselves somewhere in between and your
brain has a difficult time
recognizing a spectrum and so you're
requiring it be into a bin so there you
are
forcing other people to match how you
see the world The World Is Not Gonna
Change to fit your inability to
recognize how it's actually manifesting
it's not going to do that
so so it's by
no it's on a continuum
so whatever it is you can say is is is
the universe sweet or salty is the
universe whatever it is you're asking me
is it this or is it that Ah that's the
binary brain trying to force a Continuum
into two categories so it's like Chex
Mix
except with more objects more kinds of
objects than what you find in check
checks mix has like five things in it
yeah that's true okay imagine if Chex
Mix had everything in a Continuum and it
kept changing now look at how our brain
works we have hurricane strengths right
oh yeah they measure this wind speed
do you realize it's a continuum
but we we divided it into five
categories right but it's a Continuum do
you realize you can go from low category
three to high category three and it's
and they'll just talk about uh Irma is
still a category three one mile an hour
faster
and it's category four it's breaking
news oh yeah hurricane Irma is now
category four yeah excuse me it's one
mile an hour faster than it was
yesterday yeah people lie to say the
winds broke in okay so I'm just on the
winds making a bowl of cereal some guy
said yeah that's funny that's funny so
my point is even with hurricane speed
strengths we force them into categories
when it's actually a container
so it's a Continuum out there so so
because it looks kind of gay I feel like
but then sometimes it does things that
seem really straight but those are also
my definitions of those correct you're
forcing the universe into your two
categories right sometimes I look up at
the sky right and I'll look up and I
feel like especially if there's stars
out there I'll feel like something's
looking back at me does that make any
sense to you at all I once tweeted
something like that I said sometimes I
wonder
as i gaze into the night sky
whether the Stars themselves are gazing
back at me oh damn I didn't realize I
sounded so damn bi about it and that's
when people said are you high and you'll
put down the joint are you there's this
this is a reliable influx of people who
are certainly look up I feel there's a
like a thing I don't know what it is bro
I don't think it's gay or anything I
think it'll just feel like the space is
looking back at me
well
maybe I'm gay for space bro well so
I we're not likely the only life forms
in the universe
there's probably very many some vastly
more intelligent than we are
here here we're sitting here looking up
into the night sky countless thousands
of stars with binoculars it rises into
the millions of stars with telescopes it
rises into the billions oh God there is
surely civilizations there
looking up at their night sky
and they see our star
the Sun
as part of some constellation that they
identify in their night sky
and there's a Theo Von there looking up
asking is anyone up there looking down
at me
and we get to say yes we have your
counterparts
we got a field in this galaxy too most
people that could exist mathematically
will never exist wow
so right there you are a special a
living entity as there ever was amen be
ashamed to die
until you've scored some victory for
Humanity
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one